meine finger eigentlich zusammen oder ja
man sieht man sieht dein gesicht und
dadurch die löcher zu schnittigen alles
ist nicht mehr normal leute ganz
deutschland fragt sich was ist mit
unseren kindern los wenn sie diese sätze
menschen im internet diese youtuber und
warum schauen menschen ihn zu und sie
den ich eigentlich komplett hängen
geblieben
das fand ich heute raus die heute in
köln unterwegs haben wir alle das maul
halten können biggs war bei youtube
einen idiotentest gemacht woraus zu
finden wie dumme oder schlau geht über
möglich sind viel spaß dabei hallo
stunden woche
hallo charakter gewinnt zeit hallo ich
will herausfinden wie dumm oder schlicht
über sind wir bereit ja absolut
wie nennt man den farbstoff in der house
der waldumbau strahlung angeregt wird
und dann als schutz der haut was der
andere möglichkeiten
ok braucht nicht mal ob möglichkeit
alles klar berlin ist dabei trage ich
ein gut oder melanie oder c bronco team
ich nehme glaube tatsächlich dass das
wort melanin schon mal gehört habe von
melanie entwicklung ich glaube es ist
melanie ok alles klappt mache ich so ein
da kriegt man dann auch lösung bestätigt
geschichte was war die wehr sei vor der
französischen revolution und was war
ihre funktion friedrich der zweite
erbautes in england und sie war eine
sehr bekannte und große kaserne oder
diverse war eine statue in preußen und
zeigte den göttervater zeus war über
jahrhunderte eine residenz in paris oder
sie war entschloss und die ludwig den
vierzehnten als zentrum seiner macht
also dessen vertrag erst mal bestraft
voll fitte alter das ich das nicht
weiter sagte die verträge von der sei
sagst du das optisch sagt zb ja ich
schwöre auf die verträge von der seite
die redewendung bei mir wir haben noch
im schloss er seinen vertrag
unterschrieben das schloss der residenz
wäre irgendwie brennen weil das ist ja
nicht institutionelles da werden ja
keine verträge ausgabe der residenz ist
natürlich das schloss ja mit liebe
gefüllt sind okay aus dem schloss und
die werbung reicht dann englisch wie wir
das passt perfekt gebildet also wie als
der relativ satz das haus das ich
gesehen hatte
richtig auf englisch in der
hauswirtschaft erziehen oder der
haushüter herbst oder beherrschen sie
hätten alles klar niemand würde helfen
natürlich helfen welches wort ist kein
fremdwort moral kupfer firma melodie
metall kein fremdwort
stimmt man ein fremdwort dass man sie
auch nicht kupfer moral sage ich kupfer
chemie was ist das hauptprodukt eines
hochofens zink kupfer eine mischung von
verschiedenen metallen stahl oder eisen
hoch ich würde stahlsaiten staat kommt
da raus das kann sogar was macht man mit
einem linolschnitt es dass ein besonders
papier auf dem farben besonders für zum
ausdruck kommen b eine platte auf der
mit kohle zeichnet wurde kann man damit
eine hohe und tiefdruck darstellen indem
man da rein hits stehen ist die
tiefdruck variante bis kommt nämlich
fand allen ländern hoch oder tief hoch
oder tief druckt er durch ritzen
überhaupt kann davon alle drei de facto
wissen sofort platte ist so krank
ja wenn ich verrückte stück hat karl
aufgeschrieben
fortuna an der schönen blauen donau aus
schwanensee sie es ja protest an estro
fortuna fortuna
ich sage der ist natürlich der photon ok
alles klar 20 war möglich sicher
religion welche dieser römischen kaiser
hat keine christen verfolgt dezius
diokletian constantin nero oder valerius
der keine weg verfolgt hat keine
christen was das küssen veraltete
weiterte gesellschaften ist die mehrzahl
von christus also mehr jesus der klar
seine fehler nicht gemacht ich kenne
nehmen er wird das nicht machen meinte
jukic brauche ich muss jetzt einfach
daten haben sie auch arbeit kennen bevor
ich sage von nero fertig weil er roma
gezogen und ich sage jetzt ein bisschen
angehört hat video dezius ja genau heißt
der kunde welche kontinentalplatte gibt
es nicht haben ihr habt schossen aber
[Musik]
die antwort ist richtig bewusst was
schon wirklich genauso wie caps die die
ich abgeschlossen habe hh
kontinentalplatten die es nicht gibt
cocos platte b indische platte
eurasische platte die europäische platte
kokos blogger.com möglich ein team aus
scheiße nämlich trotzdem kupferplatte
glaube es die kuckucks alles klar
kuckuck klar
trotz hoher kosten
und jetzt kommen wir zu deinem feedback
bist du bereit comeback runde
ok ich lese vor das war nicht ganz so
gut du solltest du die antwort noch
einmal angucken denn das waren zwei
bilder ja sehr schön aber ich
weiterfahre 86 von 13 aufgaben richtig
beantwortet korn die durchschnitt haben
die 2008 und server die das gemacht
haben 6,06 richtige antwort gegeben
es ist super im durchschnitt 60 6 ist
der schnitt sechs völlig
überdurchschnittlich und auch wir haben
acht von 13 aufgaben richtig beantwortet
sie haben acht von 13 aufgaben richtig
beantwortet dafür ist in der
beschreibung klingt ich war okay ich
verlinke ich bitte nicht schießen ja
danke das mitmachen passen noch eine
botschaft an die welt oder an einer
anderen über die auf getestet wurden was
man jetzt daraus gelernt heute man muss
sagen die fragen wann wirklich relativ
schwierig deswegen kann ich glaube ich
sagen dass die jugend deutschlands bei
den youtube und in guten händen ist und
ja ich dann irgendwann wieder hoch und
hier könnte noch eine folge was das geht
abdecken mit mir